but i'm worried because i'm afraid that
there's going to be
kind of a
false stimulus effect to the
conservative movement like all we have
to do is run against the woke we take
back every chamber of power like the
glen younkin thing right where i'm
afraid that we're going to need a lot
more i'll give you an example of what a
lot more looks like which i think
conservatives need to think very deeply
about a national recovery program i
think that this country has been so
severely damaged by unelected
bureaucrats especially young people most
suicidal drug addicted alcohol addicted
most anxious depressed medicated
generation in history that i think there
needs to be an intergenerational apology
to try to get this generation back on
track and i'm not saying massive
government programs or some sort of
climate core like aoc wants but i think
we should try to make it easier to try
to have conservatizing events and the
three conservatizing events if you will
just accept the term is to own property
to get married and have kids and
hopefully a nice fourth one is have a
job that means something to you right
that isn't like a minimum wage job or
some sort of woke social media manager
for goldman sachs or whatever right
you think that they think
that they're doing good i mean this is a
little bit of the road to hell kind of
situation like do you think i mean i
don't know if biden's in charge at this
point which if you want to comment on
that feel free but like
when they all put their heads on the
pillow when saki lays down at night
biden
the rest of them the surgeon general all
of these people that are associated with
this thing fauci all of them do you
really think they're looking at the
information looking at what's going on
here supply chain inflation afghanistan
etc and going boy we really are doing a
great job
man you ask good questions i got to tell
you i ask questions too every day and
it's a great question because i get this
all the time and people say what is the
motive right how do they how do they
judge success like what what is the what
does the white board look like
in
you know the outer room of the oval
right like are we going towards the
mission accomplished or are we getting
further away from it
and this is a hard thing for some people
on the center right or people that love
the constitution to admit it's not hard
for me to admit because i kind of
understand the left really well
i think
they're right on schedule for what they
want and i really do believe that they
want to be
a
willing participant in the world
economic forum great reset you mentioned
it you know a little bit sarcastically
earlier but you and i both know this is
a very real
agenda which is it's legitimate i just
did an hour with glenn beck on it
yeah and and it's i think that in order
to get there you have to first make
america no longer a superpower and that
doesn't mean you have to kill everybody
right i mean i think there's some
extremes people can take towards
describing this but you definitely have
to destroy our currency you have to
deteriorate our sovereignty you have to
erode the national will and then also
you have to create mass uncertainty as
what as to what it means to be an
american
and the person that's probably done the
best job of this is nicole hannah jones
from the 1619 project it's something we
talk about every single day at turning
point usa which if you can't tell an
agreed upon american story then you just
don't have a country i mean it's such
polar opposites where you and i would
look at the american founding as a
heroic breakthrough of the human story
where nicole hannah jones look looks at
it as a regressive moment in the human
story
there really isn't much in common from
that point forward right when you can't
agree on the federalist papers the
declaration the constitution the bill of
rights
and so i believe that the people in
charge from ron claim to biden they
might have their own little kind of
wrinkles of where they think the country
should go but it's definitely in a place
where they want to de-emphasize
america's role in the world they want to
weaken america and they think the world
will be better because of it this is the
most important thing though is that i
mean in the beginning of aristotle's
ethics there's this incredible line that
is hotly debated which is all human
action points towards some good now you
take out the mentally and clinically
insane from that but really what he's
getting at is that
more evil has been done under people
believing that they're doing good than
anything else
you you take joseph stalin he actually
thought he was bettering humanity or
bettering himself or whatever very few
people are actually yes i'm doing what
is wrong and i'm going to keep on doing
it it's a very rare thing and i think
that these people in charge and no i
don't think biden's in charge i think
he's a puppet be for all these other
masters i actually don't think very much
about biden um i actually really haven't
engaged much in kind of the mental
decline kind of meme verse if you will i
think it's a little overdone we all kind
of know he's not there i'm more
interested in the people behind him and
the and the the reason they're doing all
this but yes i think that from the
treasury secretary janet yellen to
majorcas to the educational secretary to
all of them i think that
they believe that they are all
doing what a good comrade should do
to try and usher in a globalist type
project and the american superpower
status of a strong economy being energy
independent a sound currency and a
national story that we all agree on
those are things that are right at the
heart of their agenda
do you think that conservatives whatever
this new wide 10 thing is at this point
this anti-woke coalition and we'll see
how how tightly it can hold do you think
we just need a better story do you think
the story of just telling the american
history say the way we've seen it or the
way that you and i have talked about it
for a long time
that maybe that isn't enough just going
back to say reagan talking points as as
good and decent as they are like do we
need a new story a new narrative to
craft to capture young people i mean
obviously that's what you guys are
trying to do at turning point but is is
just saying freedom and individual
rights and capitalism is it not enough
that there has to be something else
behind that too
it's not enough but it will be enough
this year which worries me
it will be enough to take back power for
republicans and defeat the woke just to
run against the woke they're so
unpopular they're so awful at governing
and that's the thing dave is that not
only do they have bad ideas they're
actually bad at executing their bad
ideas i mean it's like the worst
possible thank god
kind of combinate well no that that
that's the thing where i had i got in
this debate the other day and someone
says charlie we need more technology in
government so they could be more
efficient i'm like you know i'm actually
really glad
that they're slow
yeah i'm really glad that they take
arbor day off
because if they didn't then they'd be
like google which we know how harmful
they can be which we'll get into the
whole corporate side of this but i'm
worried because i'm afraid that there's
going to be
kind of a
false stimulus effect to the
conservative movement like all we have
to do is run against the woke we take
back every chamber of power like the
glenn juncken thing right where i'm
afraid that we're going to need a lot
more i'll give you an example of what a
lot more looks like which i think
conservatives need to think very deeply
about a national recovery program i
think that this country has been so
severely damaged by unelected
bureaucrats especially young people most
suicidal drug addicted alcohol addicted
most anxious depressed medicated
generation in history that i think there
needs to be an intergenerational apology
to try to get this generation back on
track and i'm not saying massive
government programs or some sort of
climate core like aoc wants but i think
we should try to make it easier to try
to have conservatizing events and the
three conservatizing events if you will
just accept the term is to own property
to get married and have kids and
hopefully a nice fourth one is have a
job that means something to you right
that isn't like a minimum wage job or
some sort of social media manager for
goldman sachs or whatever right those
four things are harder than ever for
this generation to grab onto and i think
that we need to have pro-market-based
conversations outside of just kind of
the immediate muscle memory of the dogma
of the kind of ghosts of rogan reagan
past
and say how do we make it easier for a
28 year old that's a hundred thousand
dollars in student loan debt
that was locked down for a couple years
right is really demoralized might be on
an unnecessary regimen of
antidepressants how to make it easier
for them to break through and buy quote
unquote equity in the american project
right because that actually is a really
good thing for the country people don't
burn down wendy's
if they have a mortgage
when you're renting all the time you
become a you become a perfect population
that could be captured by these kind of
woke socialist revolutionaries and so no
i don't think it's just enough to kind
of have the slogans i think we need to
think creatively about these things and
i think we also need to know why we
believe and what we believe it
the constitution needs to be our north
star it is the greatest political
document ever we nothing we should do
should violate the four basic tenets of
the constitution
separation of powers consent to the
governed independent judiciary um and
balance of power basically those are
that's the core basis of the us
constitution but with that being said
though dave i think that we have
portions of the american population that
have been so set back by the lockdowns
and government interference that if we
don't come up with something more robust
or exciting
we're going to be looking at a potential
political population that will entertain
seriously radical ideas if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell